Thomas Jefferson spoke of he referred to
the First Amendment as a necessary wall
of separation of church and state I
would just love to hear your response to
that sure so do you know where that line
comes
from so the line comes from a private
letter of Thomas Jefferson it is one of
two lines ever cited by the secularists
for keeping religion out of public life
the other one is a line where they say
that America was in no way founded on
the Christian religion so said John
Adams except John Adams never said that
it was a line that was negotiated by
Jeffersonian Diplomat it was in the
Treaty of Tripoli it was a throwaway
line to get the Muslim Pirates to stop
capturing our Sailors none of that
appears in the Constitution none of that
appears in The Federalist Papers doesn't
appear in the Declaration of
Independence it doesn't appear in any of
the serious documents and writings of
the founding fathers thas Jefferson was
probably the most liberal prominent
founding father and he gets one line in
one private letter that view simply did
not have the force of law or public
support at the founding of our country
or at basically any time in our in our
country's history